how to present your idea to big
companies I got a great question from
one of my youtube viewers love you guys
Bruce who wrote in to say he's an
inventor he's got a product he wants to
get it out there and he wants to partner
up with this big companies in his
industry and he wants my advice and how
to connect with them the right deal with
the right big company can make or break
a business right and so it's a it's a
great idea to be able to reach out to
these guys but how you do it is
important and a lot of people go about
it the wrong way and end up not getting
the deal that they want so I'm going to
give you three different ways to do it
in order of my preference from least
preferable to the most profitable the
first one is so number one reach out and
this is where you are contacting the
company directly you can find out who
the manager is in charge of the division
that's similar to what you're trying to
do and reach out to them or they may
have casting calls where they're looking
for inventors to come in and pitch their
products of them I remember this is how
I got in the salsa company I've invested
and we made a DVD and we went on the
Shopping Channel they had an open call
this anybody wants to pitch to us come
in and one of our buyers will talk to
you and so we pitched to them and we got
on the shopping channel that way so
sometimes there are these open calls or
you can just reach out to them reach out
to the person want to reach email phone
number and reach out the problem that I
have here the reason why I have a
problem with this and this is what most
people will do is because it gives you
no leverage right you're going to them
to say hey here's this great thing I
have check it out they have the power
and and that it bothers me it's hard
because there's no incentive motivation
reason for them to want to give you a
deal I give you a good deal because
you're going to them so here are two
other ways around it that can still work
but here are my two more preferred
preferred ways number two is partner up
and this is where you find someone who
already has a connection into that
business and you find a way to work
together maybe they represent you maybe
they introduce you but basically you
have somebody who's already done
business with them who they trust who
they like who they know and they say
this is a
a company who you have to check out and
so now it's not you on your hands and
knees begging please save me I'm this
inventor please save me but there's
someone who they respect and look up to
and trust saying hey this guy Bruce he
knows what he's doing you should connect
with him that's so much more powerful
put you more in the driving seat here's
an example I'm working on the book deal
and I have an agent and my agents out
there pitching to publishers they have
done a lot of work with my agent they
respect her they like her they trust her
when she says this is a good deal they
want to listen to her and so that puts
me in such a better position because now
I'm not going to the publisher and say
hey please mr. publisher do you want to
do a deal with me so find someone who's
already connected to that big company
and have them recommend you and make
that introduction the third one is build
momentum and create a movement this is
my favorite way to do it I don't even go
out anymore to talk to companies I have
them come to me and I've done deals with
some of the biggest companies in the
world Microsoft Dell Google banks tons
of companies have just found me because
they're looking to partner up with and
buy from people who are working with
entrepreneurs and if you're doing that
then you're going to come to me because
you see all the stuff that I put out
there so put out some similar stuff
build momentum for your business if you
look at companies that get acquired okay
that's a long-term goal for you if you
want to build a business or just sell
your idea but if you want to sell your
business look at how companies get
acquired it's rarely the company going
to the bigger company saying hey will
you please buy us we're desperate we
don't know where to go
we suck please buy us and save us right
it's not that kind of pitch it's usually
the big company seeing all the noise
that this little company has made and
saying we need to get this company we
need some of that here and they reach
out this is a scariest one because you
don't know who's watching you and you
don't know what kind of momentum that
you're actually building you may see a
little bit of results from customers and
social media but you don't know that big
company is watching you or not and you
have to
going trusting and believing that it's
going to work out even though you have
no idea what the end result is going to
be okay and that company that buys you
that company that you're in the
apartment what may not be the one
company that you had in mind this is
this is a huge problem that I had in my
business okay my first business one of
the biggest mistakes that I made okay
here this is it this is the goal we
wanted to partner up with a big company
we saw as being acquired by a big
company and we picked a company this is
a company that is going to buy us and we
worked for a whole summer on preparing a
presentation and how we're going to
pitch to them and we finally got in in a
room with them and they were interested
but because again I think us we went to
them we had no leverage they really
weren't too interested and ended up
being another company one of their
competitors that called us and said we
want to get into your space we're
interesting and maybe buying your
business or somebody else and we had to
do a 180 I start working on that deal
instead of the one that we spend all
this time working on we didn't expect
this deal to come out and they ended up
buying our competitor we were in the
final two but they bought our competitor
for almost a hundred million dollars
that was the deal I missed because I was
so focused on this one big company that
I didn't go off and think of other
opportunities and pay attention to the
momentum of building and that maybe
there are other people who are
interested in this so you're going to
have if you create a lot of you create a
storm
you create a movement you can start
creating momentum you're going to have a
lot of people interested in what you're
doing for a lot of different reasons and
the deal that you think you're going to
get is never the deal that you actually
get but it could be way better so those
are my three ways to reach out to big
companies and get your company off the
ground it's great that you're asking it
and start taking action don't get so
confused at all the options you don't do
anything that's the worst option of all
start moving forward and believe for
those of you watching like the video
please give it a thumbs up below let me
know what you think leave a comment
underneath subscribe to the channel
and I will see you guys soon